we used to go to this place like the  Brass Monkey was that it and like yeah  you heard of this and we would go with  Seth and he sings like um he sings on  the show all the time and he sounds like  Frank Sinatra yeah pretty much like  identical yeah and I am so horrible at  karaoke  um but I'm so glad that we got to share  in those times they were so free and fun  we actually  saying do you remember we we sang These  Boots are Made for Walking together I  wanted to go up but I was afraid and you  were standing right by me and I was like  I don't want to do this by myself I  don't want to do this by myself and uh I  was with the guy who's now my husband  Adam yes yes Adam Housley and he was  like just ask Drew just just ask her to  just sing with you and I did and you  were like okay and we went up there yeah  and I'll never forget it